[Music]
all right today's question comes from
allison in west virginia
allison writes my husband and i became
debt free except our house about a year
ago we have four young children and live
frugally on one income before we met his
mother co-signed for him to get a
motorcycle and jeep neither of which he
could afford the motorcycle has been a
sticking point in our marriage when we
were struggling to just put food on the
table i asked him to sell it he refused
and stated that his mother agreed that
it's important he keep his motorcycle
gosh
i'm sorry go ahead this is like a
discovery channel reality show
as i'm holding my third child
what's wrong with america this you're at
the wussification of america my mom said
my mom said i could keep my motorcycle i
know honey but we're hungry i know
children are skinny i know but mommy
said she gave her mother's fast it goes
vroom vroom broom broom
he was recently pulled over for drunk
driving oh this gets better i again
asked him to sell the motorcycle to pay
for the expenses associated with the dui
but he refuses
he thinks i'm unnecessarily punishing
him for his mistake
do you think i'm in the wrong for re
requesting he sell his motorcycle
wow
no
i don't breathe
i can tell you how this would go in my
house um i would have got home from work
one day the motorcycle would have been
long gone
and my wife would have said you owe 3
000 more dollars for your dui because we
got 7 000 for your motorcycle
good grief so i the motorcycle is a
token of a relationship with his first
and original love his mommy
and he's not ready to break up with her
yet
and you are his side thing
you are his girlfriend yeah it's worse
than that though this guy's a spoiled
freaking little boy he's i mean he's a
child boy child
i mean he didn't he shouldn't be a
husband or a daddy he's a boy child
and um because he thinks about one thing
himself yeah
this guy's he's this
he's a tool
um
adult
oh my god you poor girl
uh i'm trying to think of can you
imagine saying that to sharon um hey
dave we need you to well my mom this
would not this just would not have even
come up i mean it's just not even on the
radar sharon wouldn't have been around
someone that acted this way to start
with she would have smelled this a long
time ago so here's the thing i i have
bad news for you you have bigger
problems than his mother or his
motorcycle you have him yes
and um
boy child is going to be in marriage
counseling with his wife where he learns
to separate from his mommy
and learns to put his family before his
own needs and once this is called
becoming a man my son
and when boy child does that there's a
chance your marriage will make it
otherwise you are not going to make it
three years
no you gotta you got a guy you actually
have a brain darling duis with four
little kids he's just yeah and his mommy
and his motorcycle he's ridiculous this
is just
this guy's ruthlessly selfish
and uh immature
yeah this is hard dave because i don't
have men like this in my life
you know what i mean like i don't know
these guys those aren't men true we'll
play a male yeah but that's not a man i
mean that's just a little boy child
and i don't know if he's 34 or 24 or 64
but he's a boy child
he's emotionally a baby child yeah
and it's just um the wussification of
america and you moms
oh my god
the chances that my wife would tell my
son
to put something she bought him
between him and his child and groceries
you know and groceries
would be like zero none she would have
knocked him sideways no
and that's if i that's if i wasn't
around i hadn't already done it so oh my
god yeah that you know so you moms come
on
you grow you grow wusses by doing this
and we have way too much wuss factor in
this culture
men walking around that are males and
aren't men
and it's not it's not hungry it's not
some kind of toxic masculinity kiss my
butt this is actually caring and putting
other people's needs before yourself it
is a sign of human emotional maturity
correct geez
male or female but in this case you
little wuss oh my god allison your
marriage is in a lot of trouble you know
that a lot of trouble um this is this is
a mess i'm sorry yeah i'm sorry for you
you deserve better than that you chose
poorly and so now you get to grow him up
or cut him loose and i hope you can grow
him up because i hope it saves your
marriage i don't want those kids to be
without their daddy but uh they already
are so let's see if we can turn their
daddy into something
and um it can be done i mean i was a
little twit myself and so i and i grew
up so if i can grow up anybody can grow
up i guess
oh my god oh
man
no i never i'm not
we do have a manhood crisis in america